Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us for our 19th episode!
Almost 20, Moco-chan!
Ruffians!
How are you doing today?
It's the middle of the week!
But I definitely saw some Ruffians that said it's their first time today for FUWAMOCO Morning.
So, to explain a little bit about FUWAMOCO Morning, it's a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Yes!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Ruffians, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, Moco-chan, do you think a Ruffian might have spotted Pero?
I think so.
There's been another Pero Sighting.
Where has Pero seen this time?
Pero is floating.
Floating down a small stream.
He looks very peaceful.
He almost looks as peaceful as the water itself.
Maybe he's just made of water.
Water and bones.
That's how it works.
You know he just keeps on going and spitting and spitting.
Maybe we can just let him be there.
Maybe.
Enjoy it.
Sometimes it's kind of nice to just take a moment and let the world take control of your body, right?
Yeah, he's just going.
Maybe it's kind of like meditation.
Right.
He looks very round and fluffy.
Fluffy, very fluffy.
Maybe just a bit more plump than usual.
Maybe he sucked up all the water or drank some.
It's so good!
Thank you for spotting him and just letting him be.
I think this was a good decision this time.
If you ever see Pero floating, just let him be.
It's probably safest like that.
BAU BAU!
Please let us know if you see Pero again, okay Ruffians?
Remember, you can use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, did you know?
Today is an important day.
It is an important day because today is the day three years ago that our senpai that missed debuted!
I can't believe it's been three years.
Thank you, Moco-chan, for the beautiful drawing of Rai.
Rai-time has gone so fast, right, Ruffians?
You didn't forget, of course.
No!
But you know, three years ago they debuted.
Time has gone so fast.
Now they're gonna be going on to their fourth year as members of hololive.
Four years.
Ina looks sleepy.
She is very happy.
It's the anniversary.
Thumbs up.
Within this period of time, look at all they've accomplished.
All the happiness, the laughs, the entertainment that they've brought to everybody.
We really admire that.
Imagine what our third anniversary will be like, right Moco-chan?
Ruffians, what do you think?
Three years.
What will we be like then?
How many FUWAMOCO Mornings will that be?
A lot.
You know, we really hope that we can accomplish as much as our senpai have, and we're looking forward to seeing what they'll continue to be creating from here on out.
Let's all celebrate lots today with them!
You know, at the 3rd anniversary stream, I think it's starting at 2pm BT.
5am GST.
You'll be at 5... 6am, 6am.
Good morning everyone!
You're not gonna miss it too, right?
Congratulations, miss!
Ruffians, let's all make sure to say good congratulations to miss, okay?
Third anniversary only happens once, you know?
It's true.
BAU BAU!
Wow.
Next up, we have something that we kinda need to confess.
Is it a bad confess?
Is it a good confess?
I don't know, but we have to confess.
Ruffians, how have you been feeling recently?
Has your BAU BAU build been getting any better?
Has it?
I thought you were gonna say turtle.
It's so bad, it became a turtle.
For us FUWAMOCO, you know, we don't really have BAU BAU, you know?
BAU BAU is life.
Right?
But we realize, you know, the less time we spend together with you, Ruffians, the more uneasy, the more uncomfortable we kind of get.
We want to be able to spend as much time as possible with you, you know, all together.
Yeah, maybe, yeah.
You're right.
You know, we're always thinking about what we can do to make you smile more.
Maybe if we were to do this or that, or maybe something like that would be better.
Those kind of things.
We're doing our all to make things come true.
You know, sometimes even if it's tricky or a bit scary.
Scary.
Yeah, we're gonna do our best.
But we want you to know that your heartfelt messages and support and creations will really mean a lot to us right now.
I really, really do.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for giving us the push, the power that we need, you know?
If it's okay, can we continue to rely on you?
Is that okay?
I need to be strong for the Ruffians, right?
I'm strong!
I am strong!
BAU BAU, thank you Ruffians!
Bye!
Let's try to be strong though, okay?
Guard Dogs, we are tough.
Wow, Ruffians.
This is quite an embarrassing show.
I don't know if this counts as a... As a... What does it count as?
As a confession?
Confession!
Ruffians.
I don't know how you're doing, you know.
Recently, you know, FUWAMOCO, it's been a bit busy.
Things have gotten a bit messy here and there.
You know how you just kind of look down at the ground and sometimes you start to notice that, oh my gosh, there's a lot of fluff, there's a lot of fuzz gathered up in the corner there.
You know, that sort of thing.
How have you been doing, Ruffians?
Is everything sparkling?
You're taking care of everything, it's all good!
No dirty dishes?
There's no dirty dishes for us, you know, because I've been doing really well, but maybe things have been getting a little rough here and there.
The fluff and the fuzz, the fluff and the fuzz!
It just gets everywhere, okay?
You've been keeping it clean, that's good!
I don't know.
When it gets to a level then it's just like... So we were thinking, if it's ok, we wanted to ask you for some assistance.
Some help, you know?
3 p.m.
PT, we're thinking... Oh, that's 7 a.m.
PT.
We're thinking that maybe we would do our first Twitter Space and then that way we could tidy up all together!
How does that sound, Ruffians?
It's not very fun, but maybe if you're here with us, then it's not so bad, right?
Yeah, you know, we have you, and then you have us, and then we can all clean up together, right?
Right?
It might get a little bit live with some scrubbing and some vacuuming in there.
But if you don't mind it, then... Right!
Can we post a picture?
Oh, of course, of course!
A picture?
Like, afterwards, you know?
Like, hashtag.
Not before.
Right, right, right!
We'll see, we'll see!
Yeah.
Ruffians, you could, but...
Maybe the after, you know?
Show your hard work.
And if it was clean beforehand then, you know?
Not before and after, okay?
No, not before.
We'll see, we'll see.
Moco-chan, it's a big we'll see.
It's a big we'll see.
We're gonna be looking forward to our first twitters with Ruffians!
Asano.
Sou.
Shichiji desu.
Clean up early in the morning.
I think so.
I don't know though.
Thank you!
Let's all get our cleaning supplies ready.
Although, FUWAMOCO we don't really... It's not that bad.
It's just uncomfortable.
So don't misunderstand, okay?
It's not horrible.
It's just not nice anymore.
You know it'd be nicer to do with the Ruffians, right?
This way it'll be all fun together, okay?
Spring cleaning.
It's...summer is almost over.
Fall cleaning!
Let's do our best to get our hands BAU BAU!
I'm excited for that fight, Moco-chan.
You don't have anything else.
Nothing else for today, right?
Well, actually, Moco-chan.
There's been a bit of a misunderstanding.
I don't know!
A bit of a misunderstanding.
Something that I thought we should clear up, so...
Yeah, I didn't really want to bring attention to it because I didn't want any Ruffians to misunderstand further.
So maybe it's a bit late.
Yeah, but I have a day doing Donkey Kong Country.
You know, Ruffians, I asked... I asked, right?
Yeah, I asked.
You, who would protect your smile better?
Us or Donkey Kong?
And then, you said Donkey Kong.
Yeah.
So I got a bit muffled by this, and I kinda mixed up my words.
And I said, unfortunately, you're stuck here with us!
We're stuck here with you!
You messed it up again!
See?
Because I'm not feeling ruffled right now.
So I messed it up and I said, unfortunately we're stuck here with you!
It's another misunderstanding!
Got it!
Like, I don't want to be here with you!
This is horrible.
That's what I said.
What did you say?
Clear the misunderstanding for good this time!
I said that we're stuck here with you!
Yeah.
But what I meant is that you're stuck here with us.
It's so... That doesn't sound like me, right?
It doesn't sound like me to say something so... so horrible, right?
It's a misunderstanding in the misunderstanding corner!
But you know... You know... Luckily... I fixed it right away, because... You know, I know that that sort of thing happens.
It happens with me all the time, right?
Just like it did just now.
But, you know... Understand, Ruffians, I say silly things like that...
All the time.
And you know, we really don't mean it when that happens.
So, if we ever say something that you think is sort of like, oh, that really doesn't sound like FUWAMOCO would say or mean, then do understand that we probably got all jumbled up.
And that's why we said something weird, okay?
We didn't mean to.
No, no.
Right?
It happens.
All the time.
You're the silly puppy, both of us.
Why?
We're both silly puppies.
I'm not evil!
What?!
They're saying I'm evil, Moco-chan.
You're just silly.
I'm just silly.
We're both silly.
You don't ever have this, Ruffians!
It doesn't happen to you at all!
That's the proper answer.
No, you don't have this problem at all!
Really?
Maybe you should be sillier then, okay?
Maybe it's a demon dog thing, Moco-chan.
Maybe.
Maybe they just don't understand.
Well, now you understand, right?
Because we cleared up the misunderstanding.
Cleared up the misunderstanding.
It's good.
Good.
Good, good, good.
No more misunderstanding.
All done.
We can breathe a little bit now.
Not clear.
I think that's your problem.
That's your problem.
Anyways!
I had something I wanted to say.
If it's okay.
Is it okay, Ruffians?
Is it okay?
Today!
You know, it's Wednesday.
You're almost done with the week!
But it can be really rough sometimes, right?
So!
Today!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And this time, you're gonna hear from me!
Mococo, okay?
You!
You Ruffian!
You did it!
You got this far already!
It's been tough, but... You might not have noticed it.
But you're doing it!
You're making through the day!
Slowly, but surely, you're getting through this week.
And even though you may stumble here and there, you're not letting it take you out.
And that's what's important.
Okay?
You're amazing!
And you know it.
We're always here to cheer you on no matter what.
So take risks, make mistakes, because you'll get stronger from it.
Okay.
We can do it all together.
So today, go out there and make your place a good...
World.
Okay!
Just remember!
I believe in you!
Fuwawa believes in you!
It'll be okay!
Let's be strong together, okay?
Okay?
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Moco-chan!
I need a bit of strength to get through the week, right?
That's what we all need sometimes.
Doggie of the Day!
Who's a Doggie of the Day today, Moco-chan?
She has a lovely apricot!
Look at that wing.
She's such a pro at charming us.
What about me?
Is it the same?
I can't be as cool as everybody.
Moco-chan's winking, Apricot's winking, and I just... I kinda did it.
How did you do it?
Well, you know, I really like Apricot.
Look!
She's like Apricot color, too.
Like an Apricot cookie.
Right?
She's fuzzy just like one, too.
Yeah!
You guys good friends.
We're friends.
We're linking friends.
And you're both fuzzy, too.
Ah, you know.
And I love that we get to see her delicate little curls in the cool beans, too.
Very cute.
So cute and dainty, like a little princess.
That's right.
We're good friends.
How do you think she BAU BAU?
I think she's super polite, you know?
She knows not to startle anyone with a big BAU BAU like Moco-chan and you do sometimes.
No, I feel like her BAU BAU is sort of sharp.
Sharp?
BAU BAU!
I think it's more reserved like a BAU BAU!
Like that.
Like a princess.
Yeah!
A princess.
Well, you know, I think what we can tell is that Apricot, she turns everyone with her lovely demeanor, and I think she's just a gem to be around, right?
She sounds sort of familiar, huh?
Sort of familiar, right?
Yeah, but you know,
She's pretty dainty, so I think you need to treat her very well.
Like a princess.
Her own pillow, her own blanket.
Give her lots of hugs, okay?
Princesses need lots of hugs.
BAU BAU!
Let's see where the Ruffians have been walking recently.
Today I went on a walk where?
It's speechless.
This is real!
Did you actually go here?
Look at the sky, the beach.
Wait, this is a photo.
It's too beautiful.
Moco-chan is taking a photo.
I meant a painting, not a photo!
It is a photo, yes!
Wow, this is what the beach near you looks like!
You can just walk to here whenever you want to!
I think if it was that pretty, then I would be there for sunrise and sunset every day.
You should go every day, right?
You know, it kind of looks like a screensaver.
One of those motivational posters.
Right!
What do you think the motivational text would be on it, Moco-chan?
Ganbatte.
That doesn't really get me.
It gets me in the bones.
What do you think you should be?
Ruffians, what do you think the motivational piece should say?
BAU BAU I'm at the beach.
That's motivational.
I think that's good enough.
We can do better than that.
Fight the Tides, BAU BAU.
That's pretty good.
I like that one.
BAU BAU and at the beach.
It sort of rhymes.
I don't know.
BAU BAU is life.
Beach is life.
BAU BAU at the beach.
BAU BAU and carry on.
Oh, that's good to hear.
I'm really glad that you can enjoy such a beautiful beach so far.
I feel like the water wouldn't smell at all.
Not smelly water.
Exactly.
No wet dog smell.
Thank you so much!
BAU BAU!
And next, we have our Question of the Day!
What is it?
Let's see.
Try to answer at the same time to see if you both are in sync.
If dog is BAU BAU, cat is MAO MAO.
Dog is GUA GUA.
Rabbit is FAO FAO.
It wasn't the same at all.
What did you say?
As cat is MAO MAO, CAO CAO.
Duck is GAU GAU.
GAU GAU.
Rabbit is FOW FOW.
It's tough to say it all.
See, cat is MOU MOU because cats go MEOW, right?
And duck is GAU GAU because I feel like ducks go... Ducks go QUACK.
And then the rabbit is fluffy so you take the F from the fluffy and then go FOW FOW.
That's why.
I think yours sound better than mine, but... What's the reasoning behind yours, Moco-chan?
Cat starts with a C. And D starts with a D. D starts with a D, Moco-chan!
What?
It does!
It also ends with a D, too.
I'm still asleep, okay?
That's no good, Moco-chan.
That's not acceptable.
No misunderstandings.
I said what I meant.
And what's the last one?
The rabbit?
Rabbit.
It starts with an R. So it's ROW ROW.
It does.
It does, too.
I don't know.
I don't feel like that's the one, though.
Thank you for the unique questions!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, what game do we have coming up next?
We have... De-den!
We're playing River City Girls!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm really excited, you know?
We get to go back to River City Girls!
We're gonna beat up a bunch of troublemakers, you know?
Last time we were able to take down not just one Ruff, but two of them!
We're improving!
Yeah, I think that definitely means we're improving.
It's really fun to kind of bow beside each other.
Even though maybe sometimes Moco-chan punches me and I kick her.
But I really like being able to use different moves.
So I'm excited to see what awaits us!
Right!
Hopefully the bosses don't get too much stronger.
That'll be good.
That was tricky.
We'll get stronger, so it'll be okay.
I like the last lady with the dampanku.
That was cool, right?
I thought we were done for, but we did it!
Well, let's have another quick peek at our schedule.
De-den!
This is our schedule this week!
And on Friday, this time with Abbot, we're playing Mario Kart 8 Deluxe!
You know, I talked about how I feel like I'm pretty strong at Mario Kart, and you know why?
Because I've played Mario Kart on mobile for quite a while.
So I'm confident that I have at least
A little bit of an advantage, but I don't know if that really transfers too much to Mario Kart 8.
Ruffians, have you played it on mobile?
Mario Kart... Something.
Something.
Mario Kart Drift?
Mario Kart Tour?
Tour?
Yeah.
So I kind of know, but it's different, you know?
They're not the same.
But the stages are the same.
So then you kind of know, right?
I really want to get strong, you know?
I feel a bit silly because I think Mario Kart's a lot of just luck, but I'll try to learn, I'll try to practice, get more tips, and at least hopefully by a collab I can master how to be able to drift and do the super drifts.
I could do it no problem before, but it's a bit different with a controller, you know?
But Moco-chan, you're just playing for fun, right?
I want to get good.
You want to get good?
Yeah.
Well, we'll see who's the strongest in Abyss, okay?
It'd be nice to beat Biboo for once, but I think Biboo plays quite a bit too, right?
We'll see.
Well, thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us for today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
We hope you're powered up and ready to get through the rest of the week.
Oh, I have one last thing I'd like to say.
Just remember, Ruffians, unfortunately we won't be able to see you this evening, so we hope you have a really good time celebrating our senpai's mid-anniversary.
Okay!
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
BAU!
BAU BAU!
Manika!
Ann!
BAU BAU!
Porkchop!
Soda night for BAU BAU!
Jamira!
BAU BAU!
Mato!
Blue!
BAU BAU!
Kouager!
Akai!
BAU BAU!
See you, Riki!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!